I have a bone to pick with Netflix I'm
sure you do as well you go you scroll
over to the category stand-up comedy's
it's all guys what around lot of guys
tons of guys majority guys so thank you
for stepping in and not everything
there's Amy Schumer there's Cummings is
on there I think that there are women
it's funny you say that and I hate to
say no because Ted's around oh this is
so awesome and and the reason why I
think so many comedians have gone to net
was because he's such a genuine comedy
fan but someone did send me something
that said and don't just show this part
of this so it looks like I'm Adam
because but it said like I'm like quirky
female comedians and then like a list
and then I sent that picture like onto
someone else's into damn and I just go I
don't want to be you know some category
called quirky female comedians I'm a
comedian I make sure that be horrifying
to me would you say like quirky black
comedians or like you know street black
comedians I mean it's so humid category
so it's all be but it literally was like
it's like computer-generated how those
things work but he told me personally
it's like that is not going to be how it
is anymore
yeah I was like oh good and since we are
such good friends we go way back
like close to Chappelle money here for
you not even close but I'm perfectly
happy with it Chapelle is a huge star
you gave them three specials I want him
to have all the money in the world I
keep my overhead low I know that I'm
divisive I'm not for everyone that's why
you don't see me in shampoo ads or Old
Navy ads wish I could be with love to do
those I think they're funny and they're
probably crazy money which you know
would be great I am NOT against money
but I've never been one to make a lot of
it I live in my apartment I own my
apartment
I share a washer/dryer with my floor I
own my little hybrid car and that's all
I need keep my overhead while
lay low good for you we should all be
more like that in life yeah what do you
need you need stuff although I usually I
wore this outfit the other day and my
manager gave me a long necklace to break
it up but now she's gone back to LA so I
do not I don't get with her
I have no jewelry which I don't own
jewelry let's talk about your your your
special on Netflix you talk about buying
new dogs by everyone I don't know your
relationship with your sisters how
candid you actually get in your standup
here
well I always um I'm an expert what is
that word exposed exposed I'm an
exhibition
I mean I'm necessarily with my human
body which I'm perfectly comfortable
with but I am yeah I feel I if there's
something about me I I need to say it
get off your chair matter how
embarrassing yeah I think I just you
know it I'll comics are like that most
comics many comics but as a comedy
writers there are there are certain
things that you must stay away from or
is everything fair game you go after
things the way you see fit you know I
never go like this topic I'm going to
write about this topic it's just as
stuff I'm thinking about that that
organically happens I've never plotted
what material I should have or I never
second-guess what anyone wants to see I
think that's a comedy killer I just
what organically kind of comes up so
since my last special a lot has happened
in my life a lot has happened in the
world and so the special reflects that
in various ways getting this year sorry
getting that one but wreck-it Ralph too
quickly still playing the voice of a
little girl mm-hmm that cool with you
yeah I love her so much and yeah I'm
very excited about it it's so good
you'll be in your 80s you'll still be
doing the voice of the little girl
yeah hey black yeah someone bring me my
chains